[Musique]
bonsoir à tous vous regardez le 7-8 les
invités merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition nous sommes le
mercredi 21 septembre au programme de
cette émission véronique et desjardins
présidente du fonds de dotation du
centre hospitalier de versailles est en
plateau avec nous elle nous parle des
réalisations et des ambitions du projet
à l'occasion d'une grande soirée
caritative organisée demain jeudi 22
septembre
jérôme roumanie et élève à l'école
troisième il a réalisé un court métrage
autour de la maladie de la mucoviscidose
ok l'air triste marthe villalonga
participent mélanie peau qu'elle a
rencontrées pour nous et enfin c'est la
rentrée pour la cité des métiers de
saint quentin en yvelines rencontre avec
et christiane buisson sa responsable
elle évoquera pour nous les activités et
les projets de la structure pour cette
nouvelle année
et le fonds de dotation du centre
hospitalier de versailles l'hôpital
minurcat jean soirée caritative le 22
septembre alors comment fonctionne-t-il
et quelles sont ses ambitions c'est ce
que nous allons voir aujourd'hui avec
véronique desjardins danse aura beau
parce qu'on a la recette présidente du
fonds de dotation et directrice
également du centre hospitalier de
versailles alors vous organisé demain
jeudi 22 septembre une grande soirée
caritative au profit de ce fonds de
dotation de ce fonds de dotation par an
pour quel projet justement comptez vous
récoltez ces fonds nous avons de
multiples projets mais les principaux
sont de pouvoir doter le centre
hospitalier de versailles d'une deuxième
irm de pouvoir crée également un centre
de recherche clinique l'hôpital de
versailles est un établissement qui a un
très haut niveau de recherche clinique
et qui nécessite de pouvoir l'organiser
encore mieux que ça n'est le cas
aujourd'hui et enfin et ce n'est pas le
moins important de pouvoir améliorer nos
conditions d'accueil de nos patients
moderniser l'établissement est un an un
défi pour nous aujourd'hui dans la
mesure où les financements se font plus
rares et que le fonds de dotation nous
permet de les compléter
ces voix là ça a été créé ce fonds de
dotation j'avais déjà fait deux deux
opérations pour des projets si je ne me
trompe pas ces déchets pour un manque à
cause d'un nombre de moyens alors oui on
peut dire aujourd'hui que les hôpitaux
peine un peu à boucler leur budget
d'investissement dans un contexte que
tout le monde connaît des difficultés
financières
donc il s'agit là de compléter les
moyens que l'hôpital peut mobiliser pour
investir que ce soit en travaux ou en
équipements puisque nous avons à
compléter à remplacer des équipements
qui vieillissent et puis également nous
avons le souci avec une activité qui ne
cesse de croître
d'adapter nos structures c'est très
américain petit peu de faire des soirées
caritatives de faire des fonds de
dotation comment vous est venue l'idée
est ce que vous êtes une exception quels
sur notre territoire des yvelines vous
avez tout à fait raison de citer
l'exemple anglo saxons où il appelle à
la générosité publique au mécénat des
entreprises est monnaie courante
une loi permis en 2008 aux hôpitaux de
créer des fonds de dotation sans être
extrêmement nombreux à avoir saisi cette
opportunité nous ne sommes malgré tout
pas les seuls je peux citer en
ile-de-france hôpital de pontoise où le
chu de brest où celui de nice qui ont
également créé des fonds de dotation
pour
faire appel à la générosité publique et
associés ceux qui nous font confiance à
notre ambition qui est à la fois de
délivrer des soins d'excellence d'un
très bon niveau technique et
obéissant aux dernières innovations
thérapeutiques tout en n'associant notre
éthique professionnelle d'accueil de
tous c'est au bon vouloir de chacun des
hôpitaux de créer ceci est justement vos
donateurs donateurs ou mécènes comme
vous les appelez alors il y avait les
deux pour les entreprises c'est plutôt
effectivement dans le cadre du mécénat
mais sinon tout le monde peut être
donateurs et je suis particulièrement
touché de tous les petits dons que font
les patients leurs familles jour après
jour à l'hôpital nous sollicitons leur
générosité et elle est au rendez-vous
parce qu'il tienne je crois y sont
attachés à la qualité de l'hôpital
du territoire et des millionnaires qui
vous qui vous font des dons il y aussi
voilà des perspectives ce coût doit
peut-être qu'ils sont proches de
l'hôpital chaque jour exactement voilà
nous avons des dons qui peuvent être des
dons de 50 euros comme des dons de
plusieurs milliers d'euros et nous avons
effectivement l'espoir que pour pouvoir
nous doter d'une deuxième irm nous ayons
des dons plus conséquent mais là
probablement que ce sera du côté des
entreprises alors j'aime revenir sur la
soirée de demain donc vous travaillez
également avec art partage point com
alors comment vous est organisé pour que
justement c'est eux ils me sens si on
fait appel à vous pour cet événement
alors ils nous ont proposé par
l'entreprise de robert cadalbert qui est
l'ancien président de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et qui siège
au conseil de surveillance de l'hôpital
qui est à l'initiative des premières
journées culturelles
artistes entreprises
c'est à son initiative que nous avons
été associés à cet événement qui dure 10
jours et une des soirées celle de demain
nous est consacrée justement il y aura
des activités d hélène autour de l'art
aussi demain tout à fait puisqu'il y
aura une harpiste il y aura des lectures
de textes de racine il ya l'exposition
d'oeuvres d'artistes qui
a été organisée aux granges de port
royal et un buffet campagnard viendra
clôturer cette soirée dont l'accès est
payant pour une somme qui est assez
modique puisqu'il s'agit de 30 euros
pour qui voudra s'y rendre si vous avez
d'autres ambitions d'autres projets sont
peut-être prévu d'autres soirées il ya
long caritatives nous avons d'autres
projets avec notamment une pièce de
théâtre qui sera donné au théâtre du
chesnay au bénéfice du fonds de dotation
d'hôpital de même qu'une soirée avec un
grand chef autour de la cuisine note à
note qui était précédemment appelé la
cuisine moléculaire en tout cas une
cuisine inventive
ceci au cours de l'année 2010 16 ans
chef thierry marx
non je ne peux pas dévoiler pour
l'instant à faire une fois l'arrêt voilà
ce sera exactement alors la soirée
caritative a donc lieu demain jeudi 22
septembre à 18 heures pour royal des
champs tout le monde peut venir voilà il
faut juste donné à 30 euros et pourrait
participer à cette belle soirée merci
beaucoup véronique et des jardins
d'avoir accepté notre invitation il
administre notre plateau fond nous
allons continuer à parler de santé mais
aussi au cinéma le dimanche 25 7 ans ce
sera la 32e édition des virades de
l'espoir la journée nationale de lutte
contre la maladie de la mucoviscidose
alors c'est une maladie rare et
génétique touchant principalement les
voies respiratoires et le système
digestif
digestif pardon le thème inspiré jérôme
roux mind un jeune réalisateur de 22 ans
et d'étudiants à troisième il a réalisé
un court métrage dans le cadre de sa
dernière année d'études pour métrage de
16 minutes tourné principalement du côté
de rambouillet qui retrace un moment de
la vie d'un malade mélanie peau qu'elle
a rencontrées pour nous regarder
il va falloir que je te dise combien de
fois tu prends des risques
si tu continues tu peux y laisser la
fille on respire c'est l'histoire d'un
jeune homme de 18 ans qui est atteint de
la mucoviscidose et dont la passion et
la course à pied et à l'hôpital il va
faire la rencontre d'une vieille dame au
caractère atypique est assez acariâtre
et voient ils sont parés pour s'entendre
et pourtant ils voient ils vont se lier
d'amitié
est il d une belle histoire
c'est compliqué de représenter la
mucoviscidose dans un film parce que
effectivement c'est une maladie qui ne
se voit pas vraiment physiquement donc
on a travaillé avec un pneumologue de
l'hôpital cochin à pierre régis burgel
qui nous a aidés voilà on a travaillé
plus sur des histoires de respiration de
tous et sur des petites choses qui qui
se voit physiquement c'est des personnes
qui en général sont assez minces et puis
à des petits facteurs qui lui décernent
qui montre la fatigue enfin voilà des
petites et des petites choses physiques
on a pu incorporer grâce à l'aide de ce
monologue qui nous a beaucoup aidés je
comprends pas pourquoi tu te parce que
je comprends pas pourquoi vous avez si
peur que je vive le casting s'est fait
en plusieurs étapes
pour le rôle d'antoine on a vu pas mal
de
jeunes et victor on l'a vu
la dernière journée de casting et ça a
été comme une évidence donc pendant les
castings il passe des essais à ce moment
là je suis quasiment directement que
c'était le personnage donc ça s'est fait
assez facilement et on n'a pas du tout
regretté ce choix parce que voilà assez
exceptionnel dans ce rôle là il ensuite
faire jouer mart ça a été une pression
supplémentaire déjà parce que voilà on
est encore à l'école donc on apprend
aussi donc voilà on s'est dit là il faut
pas se planter elle en a vu des grands
et ben voilà la tourne énormément donc
donc c'est une pression supplémentaire
mais
finalement on oublie assez vite la
pression se met dans le travail et ça a
été ça a été génial puisque c'est une
personne qui est totalement dévoué au
projet au film est donc finalement elle
se laisse guider et voilà je pense
qu'elle a pas été déçu et n'ont en tout
cas pas du tout il est très très content
de l'avoir eue sur ce projet c'était une
expérience formidable son avenir c'est
en festival si si on est sélectionné et
après éventuellement c'est aussi de voir
avec les associations notamment de
contre la mucoviscidose de voilà de voir
si on peut avec ce film voilà servir un
peu porte parole en tout cas voilà c'est
aussi un film qui sert à sensibiliser
les gens sur la maladie sur la
mucoviscidose et sur le don d'organes
don va si on peut aussi se servir de ce
film là pour en parler c'est c'est
d'autant plus bénéfique forcément
quelque chose
j'ai encore envie de faire vous nord
[Musique]
est ont fini cette fuite invité en
parlant à d'économie à saint quentin en
yvelines la cité des métiers vient de
reprendre ses ateliers l'occasion de
vous faire découvrir le rôle de cette
structure installée à trappes conseil
orientation et information des
demandeurs d'emploi des personnes en 2
10 en désir de réorientation sont les
principales missions les précisions avec
sa présidente christiane buisson l est
et au micro de nicolet tiré le 8
la cité des métiers c'est un gros
partenariat une espèce de plateforme où
tous les partenaires de l'emploi et de
la formation peuvent se regrouper pour
mutualiser leurs compétences au service
du public donc ici notre public c'est en
priorité le public de saint quentin en
yvelines donc on
notre offre de service est destiné à
toutes les personnes dont qui se
questionnent par rapport à leur vie
professionnelle au sens large donc vie
professionnelle ça peut être la
recherche d'emploi ça peut être je
réfléchis à mon orientation je veux
choisir mon orientation donc ça c'est
pour le public jeune ça peut être aussi
jeu j'ai déjà parcours professionnel et
je mène une réflexion pour me réorienter
ça peut être je me pose des questions
par ma vie
sur ma vie professionnelle en tant que
salarié sur mon bien-être au travail sur
mes possibilités d'évolution et c'est à
la cité des métiers on peut trouver
différentes choses on peut venir
travailler en autonomie sur le pôle
multimédia donc on est équipé de dix
ordinateurs donc les personnes peuvent
créer leur leurs comptes personnels et
venir travailler leur outil de recherche
d'emploi faire des recherches
documentaires
elles peuvent être reçues sur le pôle
conseil par un conseiller donc sans
rendez vous pour savoir que si des
métiers on est accueilli sans rendez
vous
de manière anonyme et le service est
gratuit donc ça c'est voilà un entretien
individuel
et puis après on a toute une
programmation d'événements des ateliers
thématiques et ce qu'on appelle des
zooms métier
là pour lesquels c'est une information
collective destinée à donner des
informations sur un secteur d'activité
où ou un métier en particulier l'idée
c'est de rendre les choses concrètes
quelqu'un qui réfléchit à son projet
professionnel soit un jeune qui veut
choisir son orientation ou un adulte en
réflexion de réorientation
professionnelle l'idée c'est de de se
rapprocher le plus possible à la réalité
des métiers envisager la cité des
métiers telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui et
tout tout jeune puisqu'on a ré ouvert au
public en février là sous forme
d'association donc on instant on a
quelques mois de quelques mois de recul
en terme de fréquentation on peut dire à
peu près 600 600 personnes par mois le
rôle de la cité des métiers c'est
vraiment d'apporter
d'apporter des réponses
ou ou de permettre aux personnes de
trouver leurs réponses c'est la fin de
cette édition merci de nous avoir suivis
vous pouvez retrouvez l'émission le 7 8
et les invités en replay sur notre site
internet je vous donne rendez vous
demain pour une nouvelle émission et
vous souhaite une agréable soirée savoir
[Musique]